[Applause]
Tony Blair's 1997 Landslide labor
managing to restore public trust in the
party's ability to manage the country's
finances
almost three decades on secure Starman
faces a similar challenge with reports
he could lock labor in to the Tory's
short-term spending plans at the next
election the shadow Chancellor refusing
to say if she would outspend her
opposite number I don't think we should
be fixated with any particular current
forecast because they'll be updated two
more times before we get to the next
election there's no contradiction
between being fiscally responsible and
wanting to support public services in
fact I just can't just support Public
Services unless you put fiscal economic
responsibility at the heart of
everything you do
but as they stand those spending plans
set by this man the chancellor are tight
so much so that faced with stubborn
inflation and low growth current
treasury ministers are sounding cold on
the prospect of tax cuts anytime soon
I'm a conservative so of course I want
our taxes to be as low as possible but I
also believe in a fiscal responsibility
and so coming out of the of the pandemic
when we spent 400 billion pounds
supporting people through furlough we
have to now pay back that money and act
responsibly with those debts
plans for how to run this place take up
much of a party's Manifesto but amid a
cost of living crisis the numbers will
matter more than ever at the coming
election Rachel Reeves is promising a
steady ship here at the treasury if
labor gets into power but that promise
of cautious spending worries others in
the party who want to see more money
going into public services and more
broadly a bolder offer to the country
a recent scaling back on the timings
around a green investment package was
seen as evidence of this tension
one Economist says current labor plans
to raise money are relatively modest I
think at the moment it's fair to say
that if you tot up all the existing
commitments from labor on taxes in the
single digit uh billions if they stick
to that sort of envelope that does make
it harder to deal with challenges like
social care like the NHS um like
improving child care
dubbed the Iron Chancellor the
challenges for labor now are arguably
bigger than those faced by Gordon Brown
in the 90s whether the party has the
metal to address them may soon become
clear robhouse sky news in Westminster